I'll just look what I I see what I like
it's not really is what it is everyone's
got different tastes you know what does
your ideal Man look like High financial
situation it changed I I don't know I
haven't really got a tight but if I'm on
here so it is I don't know I wouldn't
say a certain height that what's the
minimum height that you date my height
probably I'm five five so my heart so
you better get your dick how tall do you
how many okay last last two three X's
how tall were they they um were like
five eight five nine okay so they were
both five eight five nine yeah about
that what the um my first boyfriend was
was taller but the the last two yeah
they've been they haven't been that much
taller than me no but a couple of inches
okay but so it sounds like they're a
similar height yeah but what about
saying that what about being with taller
blow it's like day two what about what
about race same race no mixed they were
they both mixed not like mixed races but
it's just a mix that I'm not I'm not a
racist so I'm up for you